for usual you know I'm not that I'm on
reddit but I've read a relationship
advice headline that well we don't have
to get in the whole thing I just need to
read the title of the post cuz I just my
[ __ ] eyes widened so hard my 38 year
old email dad 59 year old male dates
younger women and he even had a serious
relationship with my best friend
female 34 but this time he's crossed the
line he's seeing my stepsister who's 39
what do what first of all I don't care
how old and how eligible consent you're
not dating my best friend as my parent
you're not [ __ ] my best friend I was
about to say this dad might this dad
must got like some swag or something
anything he's a sexy ass dad I don't
know I mean because these girls know
that this is wrong too right no no that
stepsisters also dating her stepsisters
dad that's true
isn't that [ __ ] weird for her too
yeah isn't it weird to date your best
friend's dad yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
weird I guess it's like well maybe he's
just like a you know like a brad pitt
looking dude just the hottest [ __ ]
day I don't know it's just that's my dad
yeah but no it's it's messed up of the
dad yeah to do that [ __ ] yeah I'm sure
he feels really bad but I was just
saying how is he pulling that off oh
this is horrible
this is so bad stop making that sound
dude Oh Oh Marshall uh yeah oh oh yeah
that's that's what it's more of like a
[Laughter]
disappointed but like a little bit on
the bar still uh oh wait wait wait wait
[ __ ] all this what I - how'd I forget
this the [ __ ] reviews you guys left
on the podcast oh yeah yeah Jericho eyes
Alaska zone was hysterical
last episode I you know I inquired for
our listeners to leave us a couple
reviews on iTunes you know pump that
number up a little bit yeah cuz there's
something like we have like 17,000 now
or something like that let's see
we have 17,000 reviews what's up what no
I thought there's gonna be longer pause
those being the dad again
no no 17,000 seven little queer you and
and so here I'm gonna die this is my
daughter's best friend would queef all
the time gonna stop dude no room for ya
oh wait I got it did you see my
relationship advice one that I said oh
yeah what I'm forgetting it I want to
read that one after - let me say it let
me read some of these reviews first okay
these two in succession I was trying to
scroll down the page like they're all
like that now I was hysterical in
alright this one's from Emily Rose -
three - three
she says the title is best for computer
science majors and the review says I
love it when they talked about the
importance of 7400 quad NAND gate chips
and how they're superior to other types
of chips and computer architecture I've
learned so much about computer
architecture from them my professor lets
me teach the class now must listen the
next one is love how knowledgeable they
are on dot dot dot the reason these guys
can funny occasionally but really it's
just so informative I've learned so much
about how to pour some hints and they've
really helped me turn my life around
now the next one says 10 out of 10 and
then the review says 11 out of 10 pour
cement just cement and computer science
so [ __ ] opposite you
there's like random is they oh I'm one
with this podcast as well let me check
that let me check out the reviews
he's just sooo the people are saying
instruction worker playing this on the
way home yeah well this [ __ ] six-pack
and he's like so they ever gonna talk
about concrete or if I've been have i
been duped here's one i love when they
rate and compare all the vacuum choices
out there it's refreshing to hear do
people as you are as passionate and
informed by the types and construct such
fine machinery I don't like boobs
I don't like boobs at the end that's
good
that's [ __ ] good alright here you know
what I also want to play real quick yeah
can you grab your computer No
[Laughter]
and I can't yeah yeah now that's not
coming that's none of the force would do
it but it's not doing it you ever try
that as a kid no that's outward that's
gonna blast one further away yeah yeah
pull it in yeah yeah yeah no it's not
working try to move [ __ ] with your mind
yeah yeah didn't work I wanna play the
jingles no no that's but that's bone
exclusive no it's not yes bone exclusive
no it's not no dude that's that's bonus
with Daddy why because there's real ads
on this [ __ ] show it's bone exclusive
all right fine I'm pissed and I know
they're pissed right now
hey man I'm just saying as he as the EP
I'm making the call yeah that's fine
that's fine making the call what you're
so here let me read this one yeah this
is a relationship advice one I got you
hooked on this I'm proud man yeah I mean
someone somebody actually deemed this to
me and I thought it was really [ __ ]
you hack my 29 female husband 31 male
has become obsessed with taking over his
dad's company since watching succession
on HBO my husband and I were late to the
party when it came to succession on HBO
we finally binge too watched the entire
first season and all the current season
2 episodes great show by the way I agree
yeah yeah as a side note my fil
father-in-law father-in-law owns a
Halloween party type store and it's not
even his main hustle but he's always
been really into Halloween
sick sick my husband has become
increasingly obsessed with unseating his
father from the Halloween store and I
think it has something to do succession
that is so funny he told me after we
watched season 1 that he was troubled
that his father hasn't named his
successor successor for the Halloween
store I thought he was joking
[ __ ]
a few days later he posed this question
directly to his dad who said
nonchalantly that his sister 27 would
most likely take over because she lives
nearby and doesn't already work
full-time but he obviously thought the
question was odd because he's 56 and not
really close to being on
fit to run a Halloween seasonal store
then my husband started trying to find
evidence that his dad was no longer fit
to run the store he told me he had a
meeting with the store shareholders but
later I found out he had just accosted
two teenage boys I checked
dude what if this feel writer is
pitching this [ __ ] show [ __ ] outta
here this is so big dude it's why can't
you just believe this [ __ ] it's funnier
I don't know man I'm being a wet blanket
I'm sorry it's definitely funny a coffee
at the two teenager or a teenage boy who
checked into his store on Facebook and
inform an informed them that the store
clearly needed new management he also
asked me if I could if I would consider
consulting for the store part-time
remotely as a way to unravel things from
the inside oh my god dude I mean yeah
it's definitely fake it's [ __ ]
hilarious
that's that's I can't wait till that
show comes out in five years um what are
they gonna call it what's gonna be the
plug this gets weird as [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh oh now he's drawn in go ahead then
the sexual stuff got weird okay all
right this is a Showtime show I'm not a
stranger to kinks but he's now asking me
to blow him and spit his low didn't do
it okay all right we're just fine but
again this is from succession all right
imagine is every modeling your life
around succession just is everything you
handle Roy you want to be him yeah just
wake up the next day just yeah honey I'm
going to the work now don't [ __ ] with me
tiny little bird baby I'll tie you up in
stuff you full of cash I'll make you my
tiny cash [ __ ] pay pig all right let me
- hon have a good day [ __ ] off that's
that's the most settin thing on the show
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
here's one here's a fun little so you're
this app tick-tock no it's like mmm it's
like a it's like it's a place to post
video so it's not like YouTube
apparently but it's only um
you can only do a minute uh which I
don't understand cuz you'd want to watch
a full video right you know right if I
wanted to post say you know um my
traffic stops I need more than a minute
and I like to post my traffic stops to
Facebook okay you know cuz I read that
you know the police they can't really be
doing the things that they're doing so
I'm leaving evidence online so that you
know I'm doing my part anyway now real
um tick tock kids and people are busting
open pregnancy tests uh-huh
because there's a pill in there so so
people bust it open and they're like oh
it's Plan B it's inside the oh it's Plan
B oh my god they put a plan B inside the
pregnancy test that's so [ __ ] up
whatever it's a [ __ ] like uh it's like
an anti like moisture pill hold on let
me goddamn it
alright yeah yeah yeah it's included to
absorb moisture so I get so like the
dead like the actual like chip in there
doesn't like get you know okay
maybe because people like maybe there's
a tendency to leave like those types of
things in like a bathroom or something
like that yeah so the pill is in there
to absorb moisture so that like yeah I
get it but what so what's this okay I
don't come with this really taking the
pill so that's what they're like the PSA
is like do not [ __ ] take that pill
because tons of kids are busting them
all up in on tik-tok and being like
there's a [ __ ] you know my god oh my god
and you got adults doing it that's the
saddest [ __ ] that I've seen it's like
adults trying to get clicks and they're
like yo it up take stalkers me and Bill
here we're gonna crack open a pregnancy
test yeah yeah if you're if you're an
adult and your first reaction to that is
isn't [ __ ] kids are so stupid yeah
what are you doing and your first
reaction instead is oh yo if that if
this is working for them it's gonna work
for me yeah yeah you got a you got a
[ __ ] you know you got a by a you got a
by an in sand indoor motor or an indoor
you have to buy a peloton bike and in
cycle because that's some adult [ __ ] to
do all right
what are you buy an indoor bike and spin
on it feel like a [ __ ] adult was the
most roundabout way accurate that's what
you have to do if you're taking a a pill
from the inside of a pregnancy test to
generate [ __ ] views on your tick-tock
Channel you better buy of a Calot on
bike and cycle it until you until you're
sweating if I ever have kids that's
someone to use and they act immature
yeah
God you are 19 years old how much you
have in the bank right now I don't know
1,500 bucks
go buy a peloton bike used I don't give
a [ __ ] okay I'd better seat in your room
by Friday I wanna see you spinning on
that thing take your favorite program I
don't care
Hills endurance flat ground I don't give
a [ __ ]
I'll see you on the [ __ ] bike you're
gonna peddle that thing and act your
[ __ ] age okay
doesn't mean I'm grounded yes yes get on
that [ __ ] bike sitting there Sport
Chalet hi out can I take the display
peloton oh nice looking to increase your
you know just spice up the routine will
you into working out not really why you
boy find them coz I'm grounded oh that's
a healthy punishment what do you mean by
that grind it like you can't like you
had an injury you have to stay
stationary what's going on what do you
mean by grounded I just might
sorry I looked at my phone and I lost it
I lost it but you lost you I lost it I
can't believe you just said that get a
peloton bike that is so obscure dude
well I mean like that's that's some [ __ ]
that adults do you know you got it you
[ __ ] bike on a peloton bike dedicate
it by that in Dorset you don't forget a
peloton you know that's like that does a
little bit you know out of budget for
like everyone but like by like indoor
cycle and go cycling you know go to a
spin class yeah go to a [ __ ] spin
class if you look if you're on tik-tok
thinking about ways that you can you can
[ __ ] generate older older than 22 and
you're older than 22 and it's like shock
value based [ __ ] yeah go to a spin class
spin it out spin it out yeah I want you
to sweat out all your stupid immature
ideas yeah speaking wait wait hold on
but no way you hold on what okay it's
wait what real quick do you imagine that
poor girl a few weeks later who barstool
that's what I'm trying to get at here
tell me full come and there's stupid
[ __ ] boyfriend's like you know
there's a [ __ ] she's like you think
and he's like I mean she's like [ __ ]
let's do it and she [ __ ] pops it and
it's just [ __ ] like instantly just
dries the [ __ ] out of her this is
[ __ ] anti moisture because she takes
it she's like oh just he's like what
babe that's the pill suck on the comedy
about it it has to kill although come
has to reduce all the common the
moisture so all that so it all dies
[Music]